what worries you right now about I mean
you've been very open about lots of
issues on Twitter what would be your top
worry about where things are right now
right right now the the health of the
conversation so our purpose is to is to
serve the public conversation and we
have seen a number of attacks on it
we've seen abuse we've seen harassment
we've seen manipulation automation human
coordination misinformation okay so
these are all these are all dynamics
that we were not expecting thirteen
years ago when we were certain the when
we're starting the company but we do now
see them at scale and what worries me
most is just our ability to address it
in a systemic way that is scalable that
has a rigorous understanding of how
we're taking action a transparent
understanding if I were taking action
and a rigorous appeals process for when
we're wrong because we will we will be
wrong and I'm really glad to hear that
that's something that concerns you
because I think you know there's been a
lot written about people who feel
they've been abused and harassed on
Twitter and I think no one more so than
women and women of color and black women
and there's been data that's come out
you know Amnesty International put out a
report a few months ago where they
showed that a subset of active black
female twitter users were receiving on
average one in ten of their tweets were
some form of harassment and so even when
you think about health for the community
on Twitter I'm interested to hear
specific you know health for everyone
but specifically how are you looking to
make Twitter a safe space for that
subset for women for women of color and
black women yeah so it's a it's a pretty
terrible situation when you're you're
coming to a service that ideally you're
you know you you want to learn something
about the world and you spend the
majority of your time
reporting abuse receiving abuse
receiving harassment so we what we're
we're looking most deeply at is just the
incentives that the platform naturally
provides and the service provides right
now the dynamic of the system makes it
super easy to harass and to abuse others
through the service and unfortunately
the majority of our system in the past
worked entirely based on people
reporting harassment and abuse so about
midway last year we decided that we were
going to apply a lot more machine
learning a lot more deep deep learning
to the problem and try to be a lot more
proactive around where abuse is
happening so that we can take the burden
off the victim completely and we've made
some we made some progress recently
about 38% of abusive tweets are now
proactively identified our machine
learning algorithms so people don't
actually have to report them but those
that are identified are still reviewed
by humans so we do not take down content
or accounts without human actually
reviewing it but that was from zero
percent just a year ago so that meant at
that zero percent every single person
who received abuse had to actually
report it which was a lot of work for
them a lot of work for us and just
ultimately unfair the other thing that
we're doing is making sure that we as a
company have representation of all the
communities that we're trying to serve
we can't build a business that is
successful unless we have a diversity of
perspective inside over walls that
actually feel these issues every single
day and that's not just with the team
that's doing the work it's also within
our leadership as well so we need to
continue to build empathy for what
people are experiencing and give them
better tools to act on it and also give
our customers a much better and easier
approach to handle some of the things
that they're saying so a lot of a lot of
what we're doing is around technology
but we're also looking at the
the incentives on the service would what
does Twitter incentivize you to do when
you first have opened up and in the past
its incented a lot of outrage its
incented a lot of mob mob behavior it's
incepted a lot of group harassment and
we have to look a lot deeper at some of
the fundamentals of what the service is
doing to make the bigger ships we can
make a bunch of small shifts around
technology as I just described but
ultimately we have to look deeply at the
dynamics in the network itself and
that's what we're doing right now but
and what's your sense like what is the
kind of thing that you might be able to
change that would actually fundamentally
shift behavior well one I mean one of
the things we we started the service
with this concept of following an
account as an example and I I don't
believe that's why people actually come
to Twitter I believe Twitter is is best
as a as an interest-based Network people
come with a particular interest if to do
a ton of work to find and follow the
related accounts around this interest
what we could do instead is allow you to
follow an interest and follow a hashtag
follow a trend follow a community which
gives us the opportunity to show all the
accounts all the topics all the moments
all the hashtags that are associated
with that with that particular topic in
interest which really opens up the the
perspective that you that you see but
that is a huge fundamental shift to bias
the entire network away from just an
account biased towards a topics in
interest biased because isn't it the
case that the I mean that one reason why
you have so much content on there is as
a result of putting millions of people
around the world in this this kind of
gladiatorial contests with each other
for followers for attention like a lock
from the point of view just read people
who just read Twitter that's not an
issue but for the people who actually
create it everyone's out there saying
you know I wish I had a few more likes
followers retweets
and so they're constantly experimenting
trying to find the path to do that and
what we've all discovered is that the
number one path to do that is to be some
form of provocative obnoxious eloquently
obnoxious eloquently like eloquent
insults are a dream on Twitter where you
you you kind of you rapidly pile up and
and it becomes the self fueling process
of driving outraged how do you defuse
that well I yeah I mean I think you're
spot on but but that goes back to the
incentives like one of the choices we
made in the early days was we we had
this number that showed how many people
follow you we decided that number should
be big and bold and anything that's on
the page it's big and bold has
importance and those are the things that
you want Drive was that the right
decision at the time probably not if I
had to start the service again I would
not emphasize the follower count as much
I would not emphasize the delight count
as much I don't think I would even
create like in the first place because
it doesn't it doesn't actually push what
we believe now to be the most important
thing which is healthy contribution back
to the network and conversation to the
network participation within
conversation learning something from the
conversation those are not things that
we thought of 13 years ago and we
believe are extremely important right
now so we have to look at how we display
the follower account how we how we
display retweet count how we display
likes and just ask the deep question is
this really the number that we want
people to drive up is this the thing
that when you open Twitter you see
that's the thing I need to increase and
I don't believe that's the case right
now
look at some of the tweets that are
coming in from the audience as well
let's see what you guys are asking I
mean this is genuinely one of the
amazing things about Twitter is how you
can use it for crowd wisdom you know
that more more knowledge more questions
more points of view than you can imagine
and sometimes many of them really
healthy and I think one that I'd saw
that passed already quickly down here
what's Twitter's plan to combat foreign
meddling in the 2020 US election and I
think that's something that's an issue
we're seeing on the Internet in general
that we have a lot of automated
malicious automated activity happening
and on Twitter for example you know we
in fact we have some work that's come
from our friends at signal labs rather
and maybe we can even see that to give
us an example of what exactly I'm
talking about where you have these BOTS
if you will or coordinated automatic
mated militias at account activity that
is being used to influence things like
elections and in this example we have
here from signal which they've shared
with us using the data that they have
from Twitter you actually see that in
this case white represents the humans
human accounts each dot is an account
the Pinker it is the more automated the
activity is and you can see how you have
few humans interacting with with BOTS
and in this case it's related to the
election in Israel and spreading
misinformation about Benny Ganz and as
we know in the end that was a an
election that Netanyahu won by a slim
margin and that may have been in some
case influenced by this and when you
think about that happening on Twitter
what are the things that you're doing
specifically to ensure that you don't
have misinformation like this spreading
in this way influencing people in in
ways that could affect democracy just
just to back up a bit we we wanted we
asked ourselves the question can we
actually measure the health of a
conversation and what does that mean and
in the same way that you have indicators
and we have indicators as humans in
terms of are we healthy or not such as
temperature the flesh nests of your face
we believed that we could find the
indicators of conversational health and
we worked with a lab called quartic Oh
MIT to propose for for starter
indicators that we believed that we
could ultimately measure on the system
and the first one is what we're calling
a shared attention it's a measure of how
much of the conversation is attentive on
the same topic versus despread the
second one is called shared reality and
this is what percentage of the
conversation shares the same facts not
whether those facts are are truthful or
not but are we sharing the same facts as
we converse the third is receptivity how
much of the conversation is receptive or
civil or the inverse toxic and then the
fourth is variety of perspective so are
we seeing filter bubbles or echo
chambers or are we actually getting a
variety of opinions within the
conversation and implicit in all four of
these is the understanding that as they
increase the conversation gets healthier
and healthier so our first step is to
see if we can measure these on line
which we believe we can we have the most
momentum around receptivity we have a
toxicity score a toxicity model on our
system that can actually measure whether
you are likely to walk away from a
conversation that you're having on
Twitter because you feel as toxic with
with some pretty high degree we're
working to measure the rest and the next
step is as we as we build out solutions
to watch how these measurements trend
over time and continue experiment and
our goal is to make sure that these are
balanced because if you increase one you
might decrease another if you increase
variety of perspective you might
actually decrease shared reality so I'm
speaking up on some of the questions
flooding in yeah just
like a lot of people puzzled why like
how hard is it to get rid of Nazis from
Twitter so we we have we have policies
around violent extremist groups and the
majority of our work and our Terms of
Service works on conduct not content so
we're actually looking for conduct so
conduct being using the service to
repeatedly or episodically or ask
someone I'm using hateful imagery that
might be associated with the KKK or the
or the American Nazi Party those are all
things that we they're we act on
immediately whereas in a situation right
now where that term is used fairly
loosely and we just cannot take any one
mention of that word accusing someone
else as a factual indication that they
should be removed from the platform so a
lot of our models are based around
number one is this account associated
with a violent extremist script and if
so we can take action and we have done
so on KKK and American Nazi Party and
others number two are they using imagery
or conduct that would associate them as
such as well how many people do you have
working on content moderation to look at
this it varies we we want to be flexible
in this because we want to make sure
that we're number one building
algorithms instead of just hiring
massive amounts of people because we
need to make sure that this is scaleable
and there are no amount of people that
can actually scale this so this is why
we've done so much work around proactive
detection of abuse that humans can then
review so we want to have a situation
where algorithms are constantly scouring
every single tweet and bringing the most
interesting ones to the top so that
humans can bring their judgment to
whether we should take action or not
based on our item service but so there's
there's not an amount of people that are
scalable but I mean how many
do you currently have monitoring these
accounts and how do I figure out what's
enough
they're completely flexible so we we
sometimes we associate the folks with
spam
sometimes we associate folks with with
abuse and harassment we're going to make
sure that we have flexibility in our
people so that we can direct them at
what is most needed
sometimes the elections so we've had a
string of elections in Mexico and one
coming up in India obviously the the the
election last year the midterm election
so we just want to be flexible with our
resources so when when people just just
as an example if you go to our current
if you go to our current Terms of
Service and you bring the page up and
you're wondering about abuse and
harassment that you just received and
whether it was against our Terms of
Service to report it the first thing you
see when you open that page is around
intellectual property protection you
scroll down and you get to abuse
harassment and everything else that you
might be experiencing so I don't know
how that happened over the company's
history but we put that above the thing
that people want the most information on
in to actually act on and just our
ordering to like shows the world what we
believed was important so we're changing
all that we're ordering it the right way
but we're also simplifying the rules so
that they are human readable so that
people can actually understand
themselves when something is against our
Terms and when something is not and then
we're making again like our big focus is
on removing the burden of work from the
victims so that means push more towards
technology rather than humans during the
work that that means the humans
receiving the abuse and also the humans
having to review that work so we want to
make sure that we're not just
encouraging more work around something
that's super super negative and we want
to have a good balance between the
technology and where humans can actually
be creative which is the judgment of of
the rules
and not just all the mechanical stuff of
finding them and reporting them so
that's how we think about it I'm I'm
curious to dig in more about what you
said I mean I love that you said you
know you are looking for ways to retweet
the fundamental design of the system to
discourage some of the sort of reactive
behavior and perhaps to use Tristan
Harris type language you know engage
people's more reflective thinking how
far advanced is that I mean what what
would alternatives to that like button B
well first and foremost hood like my
personal goal with the service is that I
believe fundamentally that public
conversation is critical there are
existential problems facing the world
that are facing the entire world not any
one particular nation-state that global
public conversation benefits and then
that's one of the unique dynamics of
Twitter is it is completely open it is
completely public it is completely fluid
and anyone can see any other
conversation and participate in it so
there are conversations like climate
change there are conversations like the
displacement in the work through
artificial intelligence their climate
their conversations like economic
disparity no matter what any one nation
state does they will not be able to
solve a problem one it takes four it
takes coordination around the world and
that's where I think Twitter can play a
part the second thing is that Twitter
right now when you go to it you don't
necessarily walk away feeling like you
learned something some people do some
people have a very very rich Network
very rich community that they learn from
every single day but it takes a lot of
work and a lot of time to build up to
that so we want to get people to those
topics and those interests much much
faster and make sure that they're
finding something that no matter how
much time they spend on Twitter and I
don't want to maximize the time on
Twitter I want to maximize what they
actually take away from and what they
learn from it and well-cut do you though
because that's the cool question that a
lot of people want to know is surely
you're constrained to a huge extent by
the fact you know a public company
you've got investors pressing on you the
number one way you make your money is
from advertising that depends on user
engagement are you willing to sacrifice
user time if need be to go for a more
reflective conversation yeah more more
relevance means less time on the service
and that's perfectly fine because we
want to make sure that like you're
coming to Twitter and and you see
something immediately that that you
learn from and that you push them and
that we can still serve an ad against
that that doesn't mean you need to spend
any more time to see more the second
thing that we're looking at it just just
on on that goal daily active usage it if
you're measuring that that doesn't
necessarily mean things that people
value every day it may want mean people
things that are people are drawn to like
a moth to the flame every day we are
addicted because we see something that
pisses us off so we go in and you know
add fuel to the fire and the daily
active usage goes up and there's more ad
revenue there but but we all get angrier
with each other like how do you define
like daily active usage seems like a
really dangerous term to be optimizing
taken taken alone it is but you don't
finish you know let me finish the other
metric which is we're watching for
conversations and conversation chains so
we we want to we want to incentivize
healthy contribution back to the network
and what we believe that is is actually
participating in conversation that is
healthy as defined by those by those
four indicators I take you lated earlier
so you can't just optimize her on one
metric you have to balance and look
constantly at what is actually going to
create a healthy contribution to the
network and a healthy experience for
people ultimately we want to get to a
metric where people can tell us that hey
I learned something from Twitter and I'm
walking away with something valuable
that is that is our goal ultimately over
time but that's going to take some time
you come over to many I think to me as
if this enigma you you know I had this
possibly unfair but I had this I woke up
the other night just with this picture
of how I found I was thinking about you
in the situation that we're on this this
great voyage with you on this this ship
called the Titanic and there are you
know there are there are people on board
in steerage who are expressing
discomfort and you unlike many other
captains are saying what tell me talk to
me listen to me I want to hear and they
talk to you and they say well worried
about the iceberg ahead and you go you
know that is a powerful point and our
ship frankly hasn't been built properly
for steering as well as it might and we
say please do something and you go to
the bridge and and we're waiting and and
we're looking and you're you're showing
this extraordinary calm but we're all
standing outside saying Jack turn the
can wheel you know I mean it's it's
democracy at stake it's our culture at
stake it's our world it's taken in
Twitter is amazing and and shapes so
much it's not as big as some of the
other platforms but the people of
influence use it to set the agenda and I
I like it's just hard to imagine a more
important role in the world than to I
mean you're doing a brilliant job of
listening jack and hearing people but to
actually dial up the urgency and take
you know move on this stuff I mean will
you will you will you do that yet yes
and and we have been we have been moving
substantially I mean there's there's
been a few dynamics and in Twitter's
history one when I came back to the
company we are in a pretty dire state in
terms of our future and not just from
you know how people were using the
platform but from a corporate narrative
as well so we had to fix a bunch of the
foundation turn the company around go
through two crazy layoffs because we
just got too big for what we were doing
and we focused all of our energy
on this concept of serving the public
conversation and that took some work and
as we dived into that we realized some
of the issues with the fundamentals we
could do a bunch of superficial things
to address what you're talking about but
we need to change us to last and that
means going really really deep and
paying attention to what we started 13
years ago and really questioning how the
system works and how the framework works
and what is needed for the world today
given how quickly everything is moving
and how people are using us so we are
working as quickly as we can but it's an
its quickness will not get the job done
its focus its prioritization its
understanding the fundamentals of the
network and building a framework those
scales and that is resilient to change
and being open about where we are and
being transparent about where we are so
that we can continue to are in trust so
I'm proud of all the frameworks that
we've put in place I'm proud of our
direction I you know we obviously can
move faster but that require just
stopping a bunch of stupid stuff we were
doing in the past all right well I
suspect that there are there are many
people here who if given the chance
would love to help you on this change
making agenda you're on and I don't know
Whitney I mean Jack thank you for coming
here speaking so openly took courage
really appreciate what you said and good
luck with your mission thank you so much
Thanks
thank you